ok on veut qu'ils y croient au brun
coquema taille les indiens du brésil
il était 6 millions au xvième siècle
plus que 810 8000 en 2010 tour à tour
ils ont été tués
expulsé empoisonné affamés victimes des
colons à l'origine ces dernières
décennies
ils sont sacrifiés au nom du
développement économique à la fin des
années 60 la télé française se plonge
dans la forêt amazonienne au plus près
des tribus indigènes
déjà à cette époque les ethnologues
évoqué les menaces à leur encontre
les indiens sont à la merci des fermiers
locaux est de même de la spéculation sur
les terres quand ils ne sont pas tués ou
exproprier les indiens sont menacé
indirectement victimes collatérales des
explorations de matières premières tel
un gain il ne reste pas trinquer dans le
forez ils sont en ce moment il ya des
choses qui se passent qui sont terribles
au brésil il ya des prospections
pétrolières ou une dynamique des régions
entières du brésil dans des zones des
communautés indiennes qui n'ont plus de
gibier qui n'ont plus de possibilités de
la chasse alors on voit très bien c'est
très important
le pétrole mais aussi le caoutchouc le
bois et surtout l'or dont les années 80
les orpailleurs extrait le métal
précieux avec du mercure un élément très
polluants dangereux
dans notre fleuve les poissons meurent
quand on pêche on est mal à tout le
monde est malade
quand les enfants vont se baigner ils
sont malades aussi dans mon village
six enfants sont morts entre 1980 et
13 millions d'hectares de forêts ont
disparu l'habitat des indiens a été
grignotée par l'exploitation humaine
dans les années 2000 nouvelle menace
pour les indiens le bioéthanol
le brésil est devenu le premier
producteur mondial de canne à sucre qui
sert à sa fabrication et qui ronge le
territoire des peuples indigènes
j ai pas non l'éthanol n'est pas une
énergie verte
elle est rouge du sang de notre peuple
chaque fois que l'on achète cet
agrocarburant
on achète le centre des guarani kaiowa
et voilà mekawa le bioéthanol les
projets de barrages de routes fragilisé
déjà les terres indigènes la politique
de jaillir ball sonar on ne devrait pas
arranger les choses
le nouveau président du brésil a affiché
le choix du développement des activités
en amazonie au détriment des populations
indigènes
[Musique]